and welcome to Hannity and tonight
Carnage in Atlanta Windows smash
Vehicles torch police attacked six are
arrested for domestic terrorism the
defund dismantled Nobel riots they are
back but you're not allowed to even call
them violent according to fake news CNN
by the way where's Liz Cheney and Adam
kinziger when you really need them
looking into violence and rioting
remember there were no hearings on the
574 riots in the summer of 2020 we had
thousands of injured cops dozens of dead
Americans billions in property damage
kinsiger's two busy selling autographed
copies of his one-sided January 6 report
we've got full coverage tonight that's
straight ahead and stick around for
tonight's last call the lowest grade
we've gotten so far is home a regular
call to my radio show Velma she gave me
a c well she's back and she will tell us
if she thinks I'm improving tonight but
we begin tonight with a bombshell new
development from the Russia hoax listen
to this tonight big news by the way I
hope the congenital liar add Adam Schiff
is hanging on to a sea because someone
was just arrested for colluding with
Russia but it wasn't Donald Trump or
someone from his campaign or the white
house or Adam Schiff himself when he was
pranked by Russians talking about
compromising materials remember that one
instead it was a man named Charles
McGonagall a he was a high-ranking FBI
official who worked with the FBI's Trump
Russia collusion investigation for years
the whole hoax he was there he literally
can't make this up now McGonagall is now
accused of taking secret payments from a
powerful Russian oligarch in exchange
for political favors including an
investigation into a rival oligarch and
he now faces up to 20 years in prison
now that was one of the people
investigating Trump for collusion now
another was former lead investigator
Peter strzok was yet to mention the
arrest of his former colleague on
Twitter he's too busy defending Joe
Biden and fantasizing about Trump's
impending process prosecution here there
are everywhere the disgraced former
agent is the poster boy for political
corruption and bias how the FBI has been
politicized he tweeted on Sunday quote
applying the facts of what we know of
both Biden and Trump's document sagas
Trump should be prosecuted Biden should
not okay sure strzok tweeted that by the
way remember he's the one that called
you a smelly Walmart Trump supporting
Shopper strzok also tweeted that after
even more classified documents were
found Saturday in Biden's Delaware home
over the weekend this is now the fifth
discovery of stolen or misplaced
classified top secret material in Joe's
home or office and on Friday after the
first four discoveries Biden quote
graciously invited the FBI and the doj
into his home for a follow-up inspection
and during a 13-hour search guess what
agents found them agents found more more
classified documents and markings by the
way classification markings surrounding
materials some of which were from the
president's service in the Senate and
some of which were from his tenures vice
president now remember Donald Trump has
the ability to declassify there's no set
process there's no law regarding how to
do it that's not something Joe Biden
ever had this now raised us very key
questions first how many classified
documents are in those items 50 100 500
second how and why did Biden remove
classified documents from his time in
the U.S Senate and where of those
documents been for the past 15 years
thirdly we're the top secret documents
stored there in that box labeled
important docs in photos and by the way
this photo was reportedly Unearthed from
you got it the laptop from hell of
Hunter Biden here's another question
when will the FBI raid Biden's other
properties like they did Donald Trump or
they're just going to wait for Joe's
personal attorneys and aides that don't
even have security clearances to keep
looking to sanitize the crime scene
first like they did at his Wilmington
home of course Donald Trump did not
receive the same gentle treatment
favorable treatment and every time a
Democrat or the media says well Joe is
cooperative and Trump wasn't well that's
not true remember the FBI had unfettered
access to the very room where the
documents were found during the raid
they had been there before when they
were there and had unfettered free
access they took nothing asked for
nothing the only thing they asked for is
that that room be padlocked which it was
and according to my sources even after
that point Trump hired an outside firm
to search all of his properties he
invited the justice department to join
in and they said no that consideration
is only for Democrats Biden mishandled
classified material for well over a
decade in multiple locations but Federal
officials seen to need a personal
invitation to conduct a search still
this is a major Scandal for the Biden
White House even Democrats are now
acknowledging and even so-called
journalists in the media mob of starting
to voice concern as well take a look
how does it a senator accidentally take
classified material home
Margaret I don't really know the answer
to that question so that's why there
needs to be this independent
investigation an independent prosecutor
how many documents are we talking about
dozens a handful or hundreds how serious
are they why were they taken did anyone
have access to them but I can tell you
one thing it's unbelievable how this
could happen it's totally irresponsible
and who's at fault is to think that any
of them ended up in in boxes in storage
one place or the other is just
unacceptable
oh unacceptable oh okay it took you a
while took five separate times of
finding these documents Nancy Pelosi for
her part she has a very different take
her only concern is that msdnc is too
harsh in their coverage of Joe Biden
she's angry at them telling the New York
Times quote I'm not a big fan of msdnc
of course Pelosi has more important
things to worry about apparently she she
recently invited Catholic priests into
her home to perform an exorcism
according to her own daughter I
certainly pray on her behalf I hope
you'll join me in prayer and lift lift
her up in in prayer that these evil
spirits have left her house hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else